Hi, I'm Lauren, and today
I'm becoming Black Widow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What draws me personally
to the characters
that I choose to
cosplay has always
been some sort of
shared connection
that I have with that character,
thinking about her, where she's
been who she is and appreciating
her every step of the way
the same way this
character has helped
me learn to appreciate myself.
Over eight years,
I have put together
25 or 26 different looks.
In a time in your life when
you might feel lost and afraid
and alone, these
films will come along,
and they will make
you feel less alone.
You'll also meet people in
your life who keep you going
and who are your Avengers.
The Black Widow community is
how everyone shares everything.
Even when you're in a solitary
creative process in this hobby,
there is a sense
of collaboration
because everyone wants to share.
I had been a long time
admirer of Lauren's work
on the internet.
I was really welcomed
into the community.
Especially the Black Widow
community on Instagram
is really supportive, and
that's how I met Lauren.
One of my most,
like, awe-filled
moments was honestly when I saw
Lauren's Avengers 2012 suit.
Two of us coast to
coast who are each
going to do the very best
version of this costume
that we absolutely can.
It really was just about
building each other up as well
as giving each other guidance.
I was able to share what I
had already learned, you know,
what I had the extra
time to research
and to try out on my own.
I was able to sort of
pass it along to her
so that she could also create
the best possible costume.
And I sketched it out.
I did a flat sketch in
Illustrator of the backpack,
and I was able to
send that to Lauren
to also help her
with her backpack.
Honestly, I never could
have made the backpack
without Lauren's help.
I'm so grateful to her for it
because now that I've made it,
it is one of my favorite parts
of the costume that I made.
I think this is
the most effort
I've ever put into a build
before, and I think it shows.
I hope it does, and I hope
the other little cosplay
players especially.
I love to see it.
At the end of the day,
I just want to share
more love for Natasha always.
If you are hesitating about
putting yourself out there
and opening yourself
up, there will
be people here to catch you.
The Widows will always be there.
ANNOUNCER: "Black
Widow," rated PF-13.
Experience it now.